>>Male presenter: Thank you, welcome to Google
in New York.
[applause and cheering]
Please welcome Dwyane Wade.
>>Dwyane Wade: How ya doin'?
>>presenter: Have a seat, yeah.
[applause]
>>Dwyane Wade: How y'all doin'?
How y'all doin'?
>>voices in audience: Good, good.
>>presenter: And welcome to Google.
>>Dwyane Wade: Thank you.
>>presenter: You've never been here before,
right?
>>Dwyane Wade: No, I've never been here before
only been on the website.
[laughter]
>>presenter: Cool, cool.
Now we're really, we're really excited to
have you here today.
There's a lotta big fans.
I myself I grew up on South Florida so I was
like an original Heat fan, like Rony Seikaly,
[cheering]
Glen Rice, all that stuff.
>>Dwyane Wade: How many people here are from
Miami?
[cheering]
>>people in audience: Yeah, yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: Alright represented, we've
got a few.
[laughter]
>>presenter: But so I read, you have a new
book out this week and this is part of the
Authors@Google series and the memoir is called
A Father First and I thought we could talk
a little about that today and your experience
and some of the stuff you discuss in that
book.
And I think, like many people in this room,
I and a lot of us knew you as the NBA final,
the two time NBA champion, the NBA Finals
MVP, and the guy who took Marquette the Final
Four and all that, but I think --
>>Dwyane Wade: I'm still that person.
>>presenter: Yeah.
[laughter]
I think that story which you definitely tell
in the book is sort of almost secondary to
this other sort of set of tales about you.
This kid who grew up in a tough life in a
rough part of Chicago and who learned to be,
learned he was going to be a father at 19
and I think that, that, do you feel like that's
true that, that part of that story, the story
of the guy who had to learn how to make all
these tough decisions very early and learn
how to be a father and all that is the primary
story of the book?
>>Dwyane Wade: Well, yeah, I think it would
have been easy for me to write a book about
basketball but I also think y'all can Google
it.
[chuckles]
[laughter]
>>presenter: Nice, nice.
>>Dwyane Wade: That was so corny.
[laughter]
I didn't even think about that one it just
came to me.
[laughter]
But no, I felt that if I was gonna go down
this path I wanted to write something that
I felt was meaningful and I felt that can
help others in a sense.
So I talked a lot about my childhood, I talked
a lot about my upbringin'.
And I do a lot of foundation work so I know
kind of the same struggle that's goin' on
in the inner city, kinda the same way I grew
up.
So I see kids everyday that's just like I
was and goin' through some of the same issues
that I went through.
So I took this opportunity to kind of express
that and talk about it because when kids see
me and I come and talk to them they see Dwyane
Wade, the two time NBA champion and all these
accolades, but I don't think they necessarily
understand that I was them and I remember
being in that same seat and I remember bein'
told that I wasn't gonna be successful and
I couldn't do this and I couldn't do that.
So I thought I would take this time in this
book and kinda share those personal experiences
through my life.
And also the title of the book is A Father
First and it's not necessarily directed to
just fathers, I wanted to really express to
families that's gonna through the same issues
that I went through whether it's a divorce,
or whether it's the battle between the custody
from the kids, and kinda just share my experiences
the negative and a positive of it and hopefully
it can help someone look at things in a different
way or it can help them in some facets of
their life so hopefully I accomplished that.
Oh a little basketball's in there, too.
>>presenter: Yeah, yeah, definitely.
So why did you decide, I mean the book opens
with you getting full custody of Zion and
Zaire --
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: and so why did you decide that
you wanted to get this out there?
>>Dwyane Wade: It just, I really don't know.
I've never really thought that I was gonna
write a book, I never thought I'd be an author
before I always looked at it as hard work,
which it is --
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: but I just felt that I go through
everything in life for a reason.
It's some reason I went through this process
for many, many years and still going through
it today.
And I just know that a lotta guys especially
in my league, in the NBA, that come up to
me had a lotta questions, gave 'em hope in
a sense.
Before I got custody, I got appointed to the
Fatherhood Initiative from our President himself
and to be seen in that field as bein' someone
who can speak for fathers in a sense I just
thought it was my duty and my job and obligation
to kind of share those experiences with others
hopefully, like I said hopefully it can help
them, hopefully it can give them a different
perspective --
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: on how to handle somethin'
because when I was goin' through this custody
battle, it was kinda like shootin' in the
dark.
You didn't know what was gonna happen and
where the ball's gonna end up.
So hopefully if anybody's gonna through the
process they can kinda see, "Well, you know
what this is how D. Wade said he dealt with
it, this is what he went through," and they
can see this is how hard it's supposed to
be, this is as hard as it's gonna be, just
so many different things so.
>>presenter: Yeah.
You describe yourself as an introverted guy
in the book but there are some very personal
things that you share in there.
Were there parts of it that were difficult
for you to sort of explain or put out there
and share with the world?
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, I mean anytime you're
talkin' about your personal life in a sense
is always difficult.
I've had to live my life under the microscope
in a sense and it's very public so a lot of
things I didn't want to get out got out and
I would love to deal with a lot of things
behind closed doors but it's not the hand
I was dealt.
But I kept a lot out.
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: I like to tell people that
what you read in here is a little mild version
of my life -- [chuckles]
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: especially the divorce and
the custody battle --
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: it was hectic but, and at the
same time it was public so --
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: you can go find out that kind
of information.
I didn't wanna really get too much into it
in the book.
>>presenter: I mean there's also some very
emotional stuff from when you were a kid growin'
up and some of the experiences with your family
and the relationships that you had with them.
Do you think it was easier telling some of
the stories especially about your mom and
stuff because it was also sort of a lessons
learned tale that you were telling?
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, not easy but the lesson
learned tale made me really feel comfortable
tellin' it, but it's still not easy today.
We was on The View the other day, my mom and
my sister came, and we had a segment and my
mom was talkin', I put my head down in there
'cause I almost lost it, I almost went in
tears.
And it's kinda sometimes like I'm lookin'
at someone else's life when I hear about it
or when I think about it it's kind of like
that's not my life, that wasn't me.
But it was me.
So some of those emotions, some of those memories
come back in a sense so writin' this book
was like my therapy, it was kind of therapeutic
--
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: in a sense.
So it's like bein' in a dark room and talkin'
to my writer about my life.
And I remember so much, like it started coming
back and I remember things like it was yesterday
as well so it was very, very therapeutic.
>>presenter: Yeah.
The subtitle of the book is How My Life Became
Bigger Than Basketball and that came from
something that your mother used to say to
you.
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, she's always, she know
I loved basketball, she know I wanted to be
a basketball player but she didn't want that
to be my only dream.
But she always told me, "Son, you life," she
still tell me this day, "Your life is bigger
than basketball, your life is bigger than
basketball."
I never understood it then 'cause when you're
a kid you're like, "No, I'm gonna play basketball."
And that's --
[laughter]
that's what I would do.
But I lied I was like, "Yeah, mom I wanna
be a doctor --
[laughter]
is that good?"
But I didn't wanna be a doctor.
[laughter]
>>presenter: [laughs]
>>Dwyane Wade: [chuckles]
>>presenter: One of the things you talk about
in there is with your two sons and your nephew
is man time and man talks right –
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: where you have like these serious
conversations about important things with
them.
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: And how important is that in
your relationship with them?
>>Dwyane Wade: Well it's very important to
give them their time together and apart.
Like I said I had to learn this stuff too,
takin' parenting classes, my kids are in therapy
as well, going and sit down with them in therapy
sessions and tryin' to learn about them not
thinkin' that just because I was a kid once
and now I'm an adult, I have all the answers.
So I understand that man time for them is
very important because they want it every
day.
"Like I gotta go to a game.
You all want man time now?"
So they want it all the time but it's good
that they like to hang with me that way and
it's not always just fun sometimes we sit
across from each other, and one day it was
rainin' so it was like okay we couldn't go
out so I put like a table in my room with
chairs all around it, had everybody name on
the chair, had questions for everybody written
down on note cards that we asked each other.
And I was sittin' there and it was like real
life questions and I want them to know they
can, I'm an open book they can come to me
about anything and I want them to feel comfortable
about comin' to me about stuff but I also
ask them questions, the tough questions and
I wanna be able to answer it for 'em.
So that's one thing that consists of man time,
it consists of obviously doin' fun things.
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: My kids are they're simple
in a sense like my youngest son if I put him
in the car on the expressway and drop the
top and we rollin', he great, that's amazing.
[laughter]
He like, "Faster, faster."
I'm like, "I don't wanna get pulled over but,"
--
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: but, so I got to drop the top
to make it seem like we goin' real fast and
he's like lovin' it.
So it's like certain things is just to me
when we spend time together and no one else
is involved in that moment.
>>presenter: Yeah.
Are there things that you feel like you haven't
been ready to explain to them yet that they've
kind of come to you with the man talks?
>>Dwyane Wade: Not really, I mean, like I
said I'm pretty honest with 'em.
I think it's things that they not ready to
ask me yet.
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: Most anything I don't think
they still tryin' to make sure they get as
comfortable as possible to be able to open
up in a sense.
They still a little guarded on certain things.
It's tough for them, they goin' through things
that I've never been through so I tell my
oldest son, "You know what I don't know what
you goin' through.
I've never been the son of a quote unquote
celebrity basketball player and all the stuff
that he go through.
If I have a bad game he gonna hear about it
in school.
The kids gonna talk about his dad.
So I don't know how to --
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: When I grew up everybody Dad
sucked, it was --
[laughter]
it was [chuckles]
it was the way of the world.
[chuckles]
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: and so it's a lot different
[chuckles]
[laughter]
different now.
But so it's tough, it's tough man, he deals
with a lot of emotions that I've never had
to deal with and that I don't really understand
and I'm tryin' to teach him how to handle
things in a certain way, so.
>>presenter: Do you ever worry about that
they'll have a strange perspective on the
world that's, because, I mean their life is
so different than yours was when you were
that age and there is a difference between
being the son of a famous person.
Do you ever worry about that perspective?
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, I worry about it a lot.
Everybody so much when you're young and you
get older you start thinkin' about your family,
you wanna give your family everything you
didn't have and so I worry about givin' 'em
too much, they might not have the work ethic
that they need to be successful.
I mean, they not gonna live off my money 'cause
I'm gonna retire and live off my money --
[laughter]
so I think about all these things.
It's not necessary, it's not easy and everyone
in the world thinks that, "Well, I know it
might not be easy but just give me that money
and I'll make it work."
That big and small, more money, more problem
stuff --
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: that, it makes it a little
harder.
I think my parents, I think it was very simple
to be my parents.
We don't have anything so you don't get anything.
[laughter]
Sounds simple enough to me.
[chuckles] And I understood that.
But it's tough but, like I said, I'm still
learnin' and only thing I can hope is that
I always say I'm raisin' future leaders.
My son is 10, my oldest son is 10, Zaire,
Zion is 5, and my nephew Dahveon who lives
with us as well he's turnin' 11 next week,
so I'm raisin' these future leaders of the
world and I gotta try to do my best job that
I can to hopefully raise 'em to be better
men than me.
>>presenter: Yeah.
And Zaire likes to play basketball, right?
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, it's just sickening.
[laughter]
>>presenter: So you said in the book that
you made this deal with him when he was nine
that he could play but he had to play for
fun only --
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: like he had to play because he
wanted to be having fun.
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah,.
>>presenter: Do you think that that's going,
I mean in the book you talk about how you
like to play for fun but there are times when
you're not, you're clearly not playing just
for the fun of it --
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: you're fiercely competitive.
>>presenter: Do you feel like you worry about
that with him, like do you feel like that's
goin' well?
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, I got double, it's like
I got double standards.
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: I'm tellin' him just to play
for fun and like leave the refs alone and
don't have an attitude out there and I know
he's like, "Dad, I watch you play --
[laughter]
and like what are you talkin' about?"
So, but I do this, I told him I don't want
no pressure, I don't want him to put pressure
on himself because it comes with bein' my
son.
So automatically everyone he plays basketball
with is, on one hand, they're gonna come after
him.
On the second hand, they expect him to be
this amazing player.
But if he wants to play this sport I want
him to play it because he enjoy playin' it,
he havin' fun.
I mean, he's in fifth grade now, I mean, you're
not workin', you're not makin' no money off
this --
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: so why stress yourself.
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
So I mean I'm payin' all the bills I ain't
get no help.
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: So I just try to tell him that.
He had an episode one time where he, and this
was the moment where I became that dad.
I always thought I was gonna be the cool dad
and sit in the crowd with my head low and
sit in the back.
And then this moment I became that father
'cause he was out there, man, and everything
he was havin' an emotion day.
It was a girl that he likes, she was a cheerleader
at the game, so first game cheerleadin' so
he was, he didn't know how to act.
[laughter]
[chuckles] His little brother, Zion, had kicked
him the groin so his groin was hurtin' from
the night before --
[laughter]
my dad, everybody was at the game, my dad,
the whole family was there so that's another
emotion.
So he out there, every time a call is called
he runnin' to the ref.
The coach say somethin' to him he talkin'
back and he's just not playin' so I stand
up in the middle of the game: "Zaire!"
I never thought I'd be that dad.
>>presenter: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: I calmed myself but then I
went to talk to him at half time, "Hey, you
wanna got get in the car?
You wanna go?
'Cause you not doin' what we say you're gonna
do.
Second half he came out he was back to his
dancin' ways and --
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: and playin' --
doin' all those things.
[laughter]
>>presenter: When --
>>Dwyane Wade: [chuckles]
>>presenter: when you were in school you talk
about your sister used to push you academically
and I know that Coach Crean pushed you to
finish strong in school even though you left
early.
But do you ever talk to your kids about how
you didn't finish, how you decided to go pro
early?
And what is your perspective on the whole
going pro early I mean is it purely an economic
decision or?
>>Dwyane Wade: I haven't, I haven't really
gotten to that conversation with them yet
about me leavin' early.
For me, the decision, I think everyone has
a different reason why.
Some people are just, they're so good, they're
so ready.
It's time for them to go to the next level.
For me, I felt that I was ready to go but,
and then, I talk about this a lot.
Financially, I was strugglin'.
At the time I married, I was 20, 21, 20 years
old, married with a child that ate a lot and
--
[laughter]
needed a lot --
and I was makin' $220 a month.
It was rough.
And so it came to the point where I was like,
"I love college basketball, I would love to
get my degree right now, but I have to do
what's best for my family and these stomach
rumblins', it's not workin'."
So I had to take my, I had to go to the next
level and take a chance.
So everyone has their own journey and their
own path to the reasons why they have to do
that.
>>presenter: Um-hum.
Professional athletes have this, have a pretty
bad stigma when it comes to being fathers
and fatherhood and you talk about, that's
one of the things you mention in there.
Do you think that that portrayal is fair broadly?
>>Dwyane Wade: I think, I think it's fair
in a sense the one's that they focus on.
I think just as much negative, just as much
as we focus on negative just as much positive.
So I don't think it's just professional athletes.
I mean, my dad was a professional athlete
and he wasn't around for the first eight or
nine years of my life then he eventually became
a part of it.
So a lot of fathers out here, it's no secret
about it, that for whatever reason they have
left not even the home but they left their
responsibilities.
But professional athletes anything we do is
gonna get a little bit more and rightfully
so.
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: So I think it's a lot of great
fathers as well and I think that's one of
the reasons that I wrote this book as well
to kind of shed light on those positive fathers
out there.
Goin' through this process I get it, I get
situations why certain dads are not in the
house, let me just say that now.
It wasn't me, I wasn't gonna stop fightin'
but it's not easy from a situation that I
dealt with where really tryin' to push me
out and really tryin' to make it impossible
for me to become a father to my kids.
So I understand certain fathers to move on,
but I don't accept it, I'm not sayin' that's
what you should do, but I get it.
>>presenter: Um-hum.
There's a funny anecdote in there about your
kids are out playin' basketball and they're
callin' each other Lebron, right?
[laughter]
And you were kind of like --
>>Dwyane Wade: It's crazy.
No matter what you do --
>>presenter: [chuckles]
>>Dwyane Wade: no matter what you do somebody
[chuckles] yeah, they, I mean they like me
they --
[laughter]
I'm one of their top players --
but it's, they got they favorite players --
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: and everyone does.
[chuckles]
>>presenter: But do they like know, is the
team a part of your life with the kids.
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, yeah, they yeah.
All of our, we have a family atmosphere in
Miami so all of our kids are friends of each
other's and they play.
Like, if anybody ever really like focused,
if they did a reality show a day on the kids
of the Miami Heat players, they would see
that they only watch the first half of the
game, they never around for the second half
of the game because they be upstairs on the
basketball court playing they own game.
[laughter]
Me and my kids have to make a deal like, "You
gotta watch at least two quarters."
>>presenter: [chuckles]
>>Dwyane Wade: So they are very close, they
are very close to everyone on the team.
Kids love guys that can fly and can do amazing
things in the air.
So Lebron James is that guy that does all
those amazing things, so he's a favorite.
But now he's gettin' pushed over a little
bit 'cause KD is now become the favorite in
my house.
So we got to the finals and I'm like, "So
who you rooting for?"
[laughter]
>>[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: [chuckles] They's like, "Dad
it's gonna be tough."
[laughter]
It's crazy.
>>presenter: Because you guys are, you say
in there that you guys are pretty close right
now on the team, there's a family atmosphere,
like you said, down there, do you feel like
this championship was any different from the
last one?
>>Dwyane Wade: It is different, obviously
it's a different --
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: total different team --
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: from the standpoint of what
we've dealt with.
When Shaq came to Miami, it was a love fest
–
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: everybody loves Shaq and the
Miami Heat and that team and we was able to
win the championship.
That was my third year in the league and I
was like still young and just excited and
felt on top of the world and untouchable and
then reality set in.
[chuckles]
And then, now winnin' this one.
It took me six years from then to win another
championship and I've just been through so
much in my own personal life.
And a lot of guys on the team, besides me
and Udonis who won in '06, no one else has
won a championship that we had on our team
so we had a lot of guys that really was humbled
by this game.
And so this one meant a lot more for me because
of everything I've been through.
When you go through, I had three surgeries
in between the time where I had shoulder surgery
that took me out for awhile, actually two
knee surgeries or whatever, and divorce, custody,
lawsuits, everything I've dealt with since
these six years' span and to finally win it
it was kinda like just thank God that I've
stuck with it and that I believed in my ability,
I believed in me but I continue to work because
I was written off so many times since then
and just kept fightin'.
>>presenter: Um-hum.
So since you are at Google, I thought we'd
talk a little bit about technology and the
Web.
You're one of the 50 most followed profiles
on Google+ right now, I think you have two
million followers or somethin' and you have
millions of fans that follow you on other
social networks: Facebook, Twitter.
How do you follow, how do you use your social
media?
What's the role that it plays for you right
now?
>>Dwyane Wade: Well, I use it so many different
ways.
I mean social media's a good thing and a bad
thing 'cause you really have no private life.
[laughter]
But I think it's a good thing first of all
'cause you really get to connect one on one
you get to connect.
Me and you can connect just on Twitter and
you can really feel like you know him and
I know you, we might not never meet.
How you doin'?
[laughter]
But I think I use it in so many different
ways to express myself from a standpoint of
people really getting' to know who I am.
And obviously I talk about a lot of things
that I'm gettin' involved in and I'm doin'
whether it's Foundation, whether it's me showin'
up to a book signin' somewhere, me endorsin'
a product and wantin' people to try it out
and do these things.
I do so much but I talk about my kids a lot,
you see I have fun on there, with my fans
I try to have fun on there as much as possible.
I mean I get talked about a lot on Twitter
so --
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: it's not easy to read all the
comments but I try to make light of it.
Someone say somethin' negative I say, "You
need a hug?"
[laughter]
"It's not my fault you're angry."
So, but I enjoy it, I'm amazed that that many
people will follow me and wanna know anything
about me.
I've never thought that someday roughly all
these millions of people gonna wanna know
that my life is that interesting, I don't
think it is, but I guess somebody does.
>>presenter: Yeah.
When you, I mean, a lot of this stuff is pretty
recent, when you started in the league this
stuff didn't exist
>>Dwyane Wade: No.
>>presenter: So I'm curious to get your perspective
on has all this stuff changed the sort of
public life of a star professional athlete?
>>Dwyane Wade: No question it has.
I mean this is a different time for professional
athletes.
It's like I said some symbolism, everyone
know where you at at all, well not, it's not
always accurate because I've been in Miami
and somebody Twitted all the pictures, "Ah
I just seen D. Wade."
It was the back of somebody's head it was
back in Tennessee somewhere.
I'm like, "I'm not out there."
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: But for the majority of the
time most people know where you at.
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: You can walk by and say, "Oh
I just seen D. Wade at walkin' into, walkin'
down the street with his young, what color's
that, is that teal?
Is that teal?
Walkin' down the street with this lady with
curly hair with a teal shirt and took a picture
of us backing in lookin' like we goin' into
a hotel but we're really comin' to Google.
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: It's [chuckles] --
[chuckles] That's the way the world is so
--
[laughter]
it's the privacy is really, you really have
no privacy at all.
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: And so.
>>presenter: Well, so there's the privacy
aspect right and then there's the other aspect
right which is you have this instant communication
platform to every fan, journalists, whoever.
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: So you have these younger guys
who are comin' like you that are pretty young
when they're comin' into the league and now
they have, they can just talk to a million
people by --
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: the push of a button.
Do the more veteran guys see that as liability
or like a concern for the team dynamic?
>>Dwyane Wade: It could be dependin' on the
young guy comin' in.
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: You had a, if anybody had,
if Michael Beasley, Mario Chalmers and those
guys when they was rookies when they came
in together, if social media was big then
oh, we would have been in trouble.
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: Those rookies right there was
terrible.
[laughter]
We would have been in trouble.
So I guess it just depends on the rookies
that come in if they mature or not so, yeah.
>>presenter: Yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: They's bad.
[laughter]
>>presenter: So I mean this is going to be
a central part of your kids' lives as they
get older but do you worry about them getting
exposed?
You talked a little bit about them getting
hassled in class right but like if they set
up a Twitter account or something like and
they're young do you worry about them getting
exposed in this sort of social media world
to all kinds of stuff that you wouldn't be
comfortable with?
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, I mean I can't imagine
bein' a kid and growin' up in this time.
The world is so different from obviously when
even when I was growin' up and I couldn't
imagine.
Only thing I could try to do is continue to
tell 'em right from wrong and hopefully they
continue to abide by the rules and things
that I'm tellin' 'em what's right.
And I know there's gonna be times come up
when they gonna do things that I'm not gonna
approve of and hopefully they learn from their
mistake that they're making and they continue
to grow from it.
My kids haven't asked me yet for a Twitter
handle yet, they haven't asked me for to be
on Facebook and stuff yet so and they only
10 so hopefully I can hold out a little longer.
If I had a conversation it's gonna be quick
it's gonna be like, "No."
>>presenter: [laughs]
>>Dwyane Wade: It's gonna be very quick.
[laughter]
But I don't really wanna have that conversation
right now so they haven't asked for it yet
so we still in the phone and BBMin' and all
that stuff, they still cook with that so I
don't wanna go through somethin' and see a
Z. Wade Twitter handle and Zaire takin' a
picture in his own bedroom.
>>presenter: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: They gonna do stuff like that,
like they gonna try to be sneaky but it's
gonna be a picture of them in they bathroom
as you might--
[laughter]
that's in the house, I know that's your page.
[chuckles]
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: No one else has been in here
so --
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
You mention that your kids watch YouTube all
the time and you call Zaire the king of all
media in the book.
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: I know you have a channel on
YouTube also.
Do you have any favorite videos or channels
that you watch?
>>Dwyane Wade: You know what, like I said
Zaire is, he's the king of watchin' YouTube,
him and my nephew watch YouTube, Zaire really
he gets up early just to watch YouTube before
he goes to school.
[laughter]
It's a problem like --
it's seriously a problem.
I think it still be dark outside, like early
in the sixes and he gets up and he dresses
real fast, he might forget to brush his teeth,
brush his hair, but he's gonna get on YouTube
--
[laughter]
and he's gonna watch videos, he gonna watch
all this stuff and it excites him.
Me, I mean, I don't know I go as the wind
blow, sometime I'm on it often and sometime
I'm not on it at all so I'm late on a lot
of things.
>>presenter: Yeah.
In the book you talk about how when you were
growin' up some of your new school clothes
were clothes that had been left at the local
Laundromat right that's what used to --
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, I used to get some nice
things out of the Laundromat.
[laughter]
That's nice.
>>presenter: Now you've been named the NBA's
best dressed player and somebody told me that
you're good friends with Anna Wintour and
--
>>Dwyane Wade: Oh, Anna.
>>presenter: and first of all, what?
[laughter]
But also --
do you ever think about,"How did I get from
from A to B on that?"
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, I have no idea how --
>>presenter: [chuckles]
>>Dwyane Wade: how that happened.
I got a great team around me that's all, they
push me, they made Anna be friends with me,
I think.
[laughter]
No it's been cool.
I think as a kid I've always loved the thought
of dressin' up.
I wasn't able to do it my whole life but I
used to say I used to see my dad, my dad used
to work and he delivered pretty much delivered
boxes, he might have had a sexy title for
it but the man delivered boxes to other companies,
that's what he did.
But he used to dress up on every Friday.
I used to have to get up and iron his clothes
so I know he used to dress up every Friday.
And I used to see that and I used to be like,
"Well, one day when I got to work this is
how I wanna go to work."
So my thought of dressin' up came from that
and then just goin' through life and now you
startin' to feel who you are and see what
you like and I got into a great situation
with my stylist where she kind of like pushed
me out of my comfort zone in a sense.
I still get flak, and my sister not here but
she always give me flak about what I'm wearin'
cause she like we wear the same stuff like
--
[laughter]
like, "Your pants are red, I got the same
pants on."
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: So like but like she's pushed
me and now I'm just comfortable.
If anybody seen me on Letterman the other
night I had on this bright yellow jacket,
it was like the seat covers right there and
I wasn't comfortable in it but she was like,
"Come on you're gonna look good.
I mean you gotta put it on."
And I was like, "Forget it."
And I walked out there with as much confidence
as possible and hopefully I didn't get murdered
for wearin' the yellow jacket.
But it actually didn't look too bad once I
kept watchin' it.
[laughter]
>>presenter: [laughs]
>>Dwyane Wade: My business manager she told
me she couldn't hear the first half of the
interview because of my jacket was so loud.
[laughter]
But it worked and when I walked out David
was like, "Is that yellow?"
I was like, "Yes."
[chuckles]
>>presenter: [laughs]
>>Dwyane Wade: So I enjoy it and havin' the
opportunity.
Last night I went out to Fashion Night Out
and last year was my first year here and I
couldn't believe how many people was so excited
about Fashion Night Out and it was like a
big concert goin' on, it was like everything
in one, it was like everything like so many
people on the street you can't drive nowhere.
So last night really bein' a part of goin'
to the Calvin Klein and bein' a part of the
Calvin Klein Collection and sittin' next to
Anna Wintour signin' my book and signin' the
Vogue Magazine was kind of like a cool moment.
I just think about how far I came to be here
so fast so like I said, I mean, we must have
somethin' on Anna, I don't know what it is
--
>>presenter: [laughs]
>>Dwyane Wade: but it's good to have a great
relationship with someone who's a legend and
respected so much the way she is.
>>presenter: Yeah, yeah, definitely.
>>Dwyane Wade: She's nice to me, I don't know
about everybody else.
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: I seen September, too, and
I was like, "What, I don't know about this
one."
But now she's very nice to me so.
>>presenter: That's cool.
>>Dwyane Wade: Thought I'd add that.
>>presenter: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: [laughs]
>>presenter: Let's talk about, I have just
a couple last questions here and then we'll
open it up to everybody here about the future
for you.
So where do you picture yourself right now
in 10 years?
>>Dwyane Wade: Well, I won't be playin' hopefully.
I'll be 40 so hopefully I'll be retired.
And hopefully that all the opportunities that
are being created now, there's so many doors
that I'm so blessed to be able to walk through
hopefully I'll continue to find my niche of
what I wanna do next.
Like I said I got so many, I got too many
things that I'm tryin' to do right now.
But I think this is the right time for me
to figure out what's next for Dwyane Wade
even though I still wanna play at least another
seven years.
I think that'd be good in an ideal, perfect
world and then after that I can start stalking
my kids.
[laughter]
I told Zaire I was like, cause I always tell
him, "Y'all gettin' out of my house one day."
I be like, "Eight years, you outta here son."
But so then I told him I said, "Once you go
to college I'm gonna buy an apartment right
by your dorm room."
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: "I'm gonna [chuckles] I'm gonna
live through you."
[laughter]
So I'll just hopefully move into the next
phase of my life and --
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: do somethin' that I again enjoy
doin' and but also spend a lot of time with
my kids.
Zion at the time will be, like, if I retire
when I want to will be like 12 years old --
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: really gettin' into the meat
of his goin' to high school soon so it'll
be kinda cool.
>>presenter: Yeah.
You mentioned in there that Shaq was one of
the people who really introduced you to the
world of like being --
>>Dwyane Wade: Silly.
>>presenter: young, like, but yeah, yeah,
but also being a brand or like being a personality
beyond --
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>presenter: the game.
>>presenter: Like to you feel like that has
started you on that trajectory to get ready
for some post-game stuff, too?
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, it was great havin' Shaq
at the time when I did.
It kind of helped me come out of my shell.
We would have not been able to do this interview
years ago, no way possible.
I'd have been lookin' at that clock nervous,
sweatin' like, "I got an hour?"
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: It's no way I'd of been able
to sit up here.
But so kind of bein' around him kind of helped
open me up a little bit.
He came along, he coined me Flash at the time
and kinda gave me a different person to be.
So I really fed into it, like I really was
Flash on the basketball court, like don't
call me Dwyane.
I am Flash.
>>presenter: [laughs]
>>Dwyane Wade: That's weird.
[laughter]
But so it really was big and I think it just
opened me up to people to really see who I
am and me to see who I am in a sense and not
be the introvert kid that I was when I was
young.
>>presenter: Yeah.
Again goin' to the 10 year, 15 year range
like what is the thing that you most want
for your kids when they get to that age?
Like what is the thing that you wanna make
sure is just right with them?
>>Dwyane Wade: Well, I mean to me obviously
I think I want them to have an unbelievable
education, I want them to kind of have their
vision and their dreams of who they think
they wanna become.
I'm a big believer in dream big and vision
boards and all that, I'm a big believer in
that.
It's puttin' down what you wanna be, who you
wanna be and it's no problem with workin'
towards that.
And if somethin' steer you in a different
direction then you take that road, but you
need to have a vision.
So hopefully around that time they, I'm payin'
a lot for their education, seriously it's
like college, like college fund and my son's
five years old, it's like it's a lot of money.
So it better work out.
>>presenter: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: So but hopefully on my end
it's just make sure that I take care of my
responsibility, my job, to make sure that
they don't have the concern, if they can't
right away find out what they wanna do or
find a niche that they have enough security
--
>>presenter: Um-hum.
>>Dwyane Wade: to fall back on.
>>presenter: Yeah.
Alright cool, so let's open it up, there's
two microphones, I think, so for questions
just line up and we'll just alternate back
and forth.
[pause]
You're first [ indistinct ], you wanna go
for it?
>>male #1: Hey D. Wade, a big fan.
So like you're like the father of style in
the NBA and you actually pull it off.
What are your thoughts on like Russell Westbook
and Kevin Durant showing up --
[laughter]
like clowns?
>>Dwyane Wade: Thank you, I appreciate that.
So what's you're sayin', they don't pull it
off?
[laughter]
>>male #1: Have you seen [unintelligible]?
>>Dwyane Wade: I am not the one to judge.
[laughter]
But it's not for me, I couldn't do it but
he's what he's got and he's getting everyone's
attention.
I get a question about Russell Westbrook fashion
every time I'm do somethin' about fashion.
So he's doin' his job of gettin' out there,
so it works.
But I don't think you would look good in it
--
[laughter]
and [chuckles] and I don't think I would look
good in it.
[laughter]
So [chuckles]
>>female #1: Hey there.
>>Dwyane Wade: How ya doin'?
>>female #1: Sara, huge fan as well from Miami.
I grew up down there and I'd just love to
get your perspective on what it's been like
raising your sons in Miami.
People always ask me, I've been in New York
for five years now, "Are you ever gonna move
back down?"
It's always something I've considered but
I'd love to hear what you think.
>>Dwyane Wade: Are you gonna move back down?
>>female #1: Maybe, maybe.
>>Dwyane Wade: I just thought I outta add
to the people.
>>female #1: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: 'Cause when you retell the
story you be like, "Yeah D. Wade be askin'
me if I'm gonna move back down."
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: "People are always askin' me."
I do that all the time, I name drop.
[laughter]
[chuckles] I think my kids rather enjoy livin'
in Miami.
I mean you think about obviously everyone
knows that it's the Sunshine State so they
enjoy the ability to be able to go out and
do many different activities outside, they
don't have to go through the winters, those
tough winters like in Chicago where they kinda
grew up in a sense.
So I think they like it, I think they like
how every day, I remember goin' through the
season where we won 15 games but no matter
what when I woke up and looked outside and
went outside I was like, "Ah, it's not that
bad."
I think they like wakin' up to it's not that
bad kinda feeling 'cause when you're growin'
up in Chicago, Milwaukee, Detroit, and all
those places it's kinda like, "Man, it's another
day?"
[laughter]
And you look out the window you like, "This
sucks."
[laughter]
So I think [chuckles] I think they like wakin'
up and and like, "Ah, let's go get it.
Let's go to school."
It's cool.
>>presenter: Nice.
>>female #1: Thanks.
>>presenter: Okay.
>>male #2: Hey, I'm Aaron.
If you're the most stylish guy on the team
who's the least stylish guy?
[laughter]
[pause]
>>Dwyane Wade: Let me think, let me think.
Do, do, do, do, do, do do.
Oh Joe Anthony.
[laughter]
He's terrible, he's terrible, he's terrible.
There's no help for him either so.
[laughter]
'Cause he's cheap, 'cause he's cheap, he's
not gonna spend no money so --
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah and we got, so Joel Anthony
and James Jones.
James Jones is, he [chuckles] is, I love him
he's one of the best teammates I ever had,
one of the funniest guys ever.
But if we go on a two week road trip you'd
be lucky to get two pair of jeans outta him
--
[laughter]
and more than two polos.
Like he keeps it simple as it get.
He's gonna pack one pair of shoes, he gonna
pack two pairs of jeans, and two polos and
that's gonna be two weeks.
[laughter]
It's like you didn't think you gonna go eat
--
>>presenter: [chuckles]
>>Dwyane Wade: or, doesn't care.
[laughter]
>>male #2: You gonna help him out or no?
>>Dwyane Wade: No, he's not spendin' no money.
[laughter]
You gotta, it's an investment to dress nice,
it's very expensive now days and J.J. like,
"For what?"
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
"I'm married with like five kids nobody wanna
look at me."
[laughs]
[laughter]
So I love him, it's hilarious.
So we gotta a couple guys who don't really
get into the dressin'.
They like to see what we wear and that's about
it.
>>male #2: Thanks.
>>Dwyane Wade: Hopefully J.J. don't really
hear me.
You can't tell him what I said.
[laughter]
>>male #3: Hey, D. Wade, [ indistinct ]. So
lots been said about Heat for the past two
seasons but you've been totally cool in media
I mean is it just you're a good actor or you
just don't care about what media says?
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, I don't.
I'm not gonna say I don't care, I do care,
I'm not immune to it, but you can't really
let it consume your life in whatever you decide
to do.
And I get talked about obviously with my fashion,
I get talked about when I don't perform the
right way, but no one can be as hard on me
as I can be on myself.
So yes it's a part of the job and it's unfortunate
that media does that but.
Now I think one thing that's great with social
network is you can kinda control your own
in a sense and you can beat 'em to it, [chuckles]
to beat 'em to the punch.
So it's a part of it and it's not meant for
everybody to deal with it, to handle it so
I think that we do a good job of try and handle
the best way possible.
>>male #3: Thank you.
>>presenter: Over here.
>>male #4: Hi.
When a lot of us were growin' up our parents
are always embarrassing us, we're very embarrassed
of 'em.
So I was wondering, as a celebrity, do find
that your kids are embarrassed of you at times
and of your friends, your friends' kids?
>>Dwyane Wade: Good question.
They haven't told me yet --
[laughter]
but I'm sure there been a few times I ain't
performed right they've been like, "Man oh
--
>>presenter: [chuckles]
>>Dwyane Wade: I don't really wanna go to
school,"
[laughter]
'cause they gonna hear it.
But I think it's gonna hurt me when the day
comes that I'm not the cool dad no more.
It's kinda comin' soon 'cause they already
tellin' me that so, but they don't really
mean it yet, I think so.
[laughter]
So, but yeah, it's a time where you kinda
get away from, you grow out of it in a sense,
so it's gonna hurt me when I can't, I mean,
now I like kissin' my kids on the forehead,
there's gonna become a time when they not
gonna be havin' it no more.
[laughter]
And that's my boys, man, so it's gonna hurt.
I'm gettin' emotional --
>>presenter: [chuckles]
[laughter]
thinkin' about it.
>>male #5: So Ryan, I lived in Miami for 20
years and I was at game three in 2006 when
the Heat were down by 12 points and --
>>Dwyane Wade: 13, go ahead, go ahead.
>>male #5: 13, sorry, sorry.
[laughter]
>>presenter: [laughs]
>>male #5: 13.
>>Dwyane Wade: That's fine.
>>male #5: Anyways and you took over the game
and even from before that I was a big fan.
But my real question is more about fatherhood.
So I have a five year old as well and I've
found that when I first became a father I
had this concept that I was gonna be his teacher
and that I was gonna be the one teachin' him
everything, but the more he gets older and
the more I get mature basically I've realized
that he is more my teacher.
So I was wonderin' if you feel like the same
way?
>>Dwyane Wade: You hit it right on the, you
hit it right on the head.
I talk about it in my book, there's a passage
in there where I talk about learnin' from
my kids.
I'm learnin' how to be a father, I'm learnin'
how to be a parent from them, they teach me
every day.
And you guys see I like to make light of a
lot of situations, but it's seriously I took
parenting classes, like I said I go to their
therapy sessions, and it's times where situations
come up I have no idea how to handle it.
But I'm learnin' from my kid, the personality
that he has, I'm learnin' from his history
of how much trouble has he got in before,
so I'm learnin' from them how to handle these
situations.
So I learn so much, just as much as they gonna
learn from me, it's the same as I'm gonna
learn from them.
And I always tell them when we together I'm
like, "Hey, we learnin' on the fly together."
And that's just the way it is.
There's no guidebook to tell you how to be
the perfect parent or perfect father or tell
you exactly how to handle every situation
that comes up.
Sometimes you gotta go off your gut and we're
gonna be wrong sometime and hopefully they
understand that and we gonna be right sometimes.
So I'm glad to hear that you have that mentality
because that's exactly what I said in the
book.
But some parents don't have that mindset.
>>male #5: Yeah.
Thanks.
>>Dwyane Wade: Thank you.
>>male #6: So I was actually sitting here
listening to you and I realized that we got
a lot in common, like we absolutely love our
family, we love our children, and then I said
also we love basketball.
Who's better, that's still debatable.
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: [laughs]
>>male #6: But on a serious note, do you feel
any pressure with bringing your children up
in, if they say they love basketball do you
push 'em in that direction or do you try to
let them figure out what they wanna do?
>>Dwyane Wade: You know what I'm gonna come
back to that other part.
[laughter]
I'm gonna answer your question first.
I'm just that person that just believe that
whatever they wanna do I'm gonna support and
obviously they wanna play basketball, it's
something that we can share together, but
it's nothin' that I would push them towards.
When you tell me this is seriously what you
wanna do I will make sure that you have all
resources you need to be able to do it.
But I'm all about somethin' else.
Like my youngest, Zion, he's played, he likes
soccer.
Even though he quit last year he's back on
the team this year.
And I'm like, "Ooh cool."
So now I'm tryin' to learn more about soccer,
I wanna get into soccer more.
So they gonna be they own man and they gonna
have they own idea of what they wanna do,
and I applaud that and I celebrate that and
I want them to be that.
Now back to --
[laughter]
back to the basketball thing.
I love your confidence, that's all I'm sayin'.
>>presenter: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: Anybody watch Love & Hip Hop
in here?
>>voice in audience: Oh yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: Y'all watch that crazy show?
Don't he kinda look like the guy that's on
--
[laughter]
is married to the rapper, the girl who raps,
the good couple, the good couple?
>>voices in audience: Yeah, yeah.
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah, the good couple.
Kinda looks like him.
[laughter]
>>presenter: [laughs] That could be him, that
could be him.
[laughter]
Let's go over here.
>>male #7: Hey, D. Wade.
>>Dwyane Wade: Did you say that was a good
show?
Man.
>>male #7: Hi, huge NBA fan here.
>>Dwyane Wade: Thank you.
>>male #7: I was just wondering what do you
think about the current era?
Obviously like when you guys came in 2003
that was an amazing year in terms of the talent
in the draft, but then there's been several
other years where it was just incredible players.
>>Dwyane Wade: Yeah.
>>male #6: Where do you think this current
era is in terms of the history of the NBA,
is it like a golden era, the talent, the teams,
the competition?
>>Dwyane Wade: Well I think that obviously
I believe that 2003 was that year was a great
time for the NBA.
I kinda felt like before that the NBA had
a couple down seasons in a sense and I felt
that there was new energy for the league that
it needed at the time.
And I just think now that we're continuing
to get very good young players and you kinda
look at it and understand that our game is
in great hands with all the young players
comin' up.
So our game is as big as it's ever been.
And even though the older players before us
will argue and it's always debatable of what
era was the best era, I just think that our
era's the most important era to grow the game
because we're doin' so much globally to grow
this game, so many kids really gettin' into,
worldwide, really gettin' into the game of
basketball, it's so big everywhere.
So I just think that we're doin' a great job
of continuing to try to grow it.
I mean David Stern and the NBA has done an
unbelievable job of kinda changing the outlook
of how players was kinda viewed in a sense
and they've done an unbelievable job of that.
So I'm glad that I'm in this era and not the
other eras.
>>male #7: Since you're in New York tough
question, Knicks or Nets who's gonna be better
this year.
[laughter]
>>presenter: [chuckles]
>>Dwyane Wade: There's a tough question because
no one knows how the Nets are gonna come together.
They put together a pretty decent team, they
gonna be pretty good, and then with the excitement
in Brooklyn and everything they put together
a good team.
But you never know how long it takes the continuity
to take, to really work.
The Knicks kinda have some in a sense, they
did lose Jeremy Lin but they still have a
lot of the core of their team.
So because of that they might start a little
faster than the Nets, you just never know.
So I'm sure it brings excitement to the City
of New York and as a fan of the game I will
sit back and do the same thing you're doin'
and watch and see who would be the best in
New York.
>>male #7: I think it's gonna be the Knicks.
[laughter]
[applause]
>>presenter: Alright, I think we have time
for one more.
>>male #8: Hey, huge fan.
I was just wondering you said your kids and
a bunch of the kids of your teammates play
basketball all the time.
Who's the best?
[laughter]
>>Dwyane Wade: Of all the kids?
>>male #8: Of all the kids on your team, yeah.
>>Dwyane Wade: You know that's a great question
because if you ask each of them they would
all say themselves.
[laughter]
Yeah, so I don't get the luxury to be able
to watch them play together.
I think right now a lot of it has to do with
who's the oldest and who has the most height,
so they ain't reached the point they're all
that talented yet.
But they be havin', they be competin' up there.
There's been a couple, separate them a couple
of times I heard.
[laughter]
They get real and so it's good, it's good
and some of them play together like AAU Basketball,
some of them play together.
I think Lebron's youngest son, Bronny, Lebron
Jr., his older son, he plays like he's seven,
I think he plays like the 12 year olds or
somethin'.
[laughter]
Like, but he try to humble him already.
But he's gettin' that experience so they all
are gonna be in competition with each other
for a long time to come.
So it's gonna be interesting to see how it
all shakes out.
>>presenter: Cool.
Alright, we'll wrap it up here Dwyane.
Thanks very much for comin'.
[applause]
Dwyane Wade everybody.
[applause and cheering]